here's what mitt romney had to say about
billionaires tax he said
a billionaire tax will push the rich to
buy paintings or wrenches instead of
stocks
market watch story these
multi-billionaires are going to look and
say i don't wanna invest in the stock
market because as that goes up i gotta
get taxed so maybe i'll invest in a
range or in paintings or things that
don't build jobs and create a stronger
economy that was senator mitt romney
sharing one of the reasons that he's
against president biden's proposed tax
on billionaires to help pay for
democrats social spending bill i hope
you understand how much a trillion is
romney said a trillion seconds ago in
netherlands uh neanderthals walked the
earth
so is it true so a trillion is an
enormous amount of money and the
democrats i think they are adding fuel
to a fire creating more inflation and
it's hurting the american people danny
i'm gonna go to you here why is he
saying to the average person who's
saying why would he buy paintings or
ranches or baseball cards or things like
that why is he saying that they're
trying to put their money in a hard
asset that cannot be liquidated in there
by text it's pretty simple i mean and
and it makes sense and that's why in
times of kind of crazy economic distress
you've got people out there with dry
powder who they buy land they buy real
estate they buy houses
they put their money in something that's
going to hold its value in the next
generation and that's what they do but
if you're going to tax
stock by the way
take a guess at how closely
uh take take a guess at the co-movement
we call it correlation at the
co-movement of the s p 500 the biggest
stock market in the world and ceo
confidence so how happy a ceo is
compared to the s p 500 how close of a
relationship do you think that is
ceo confidence versus s p 500
how close of a core relation it is
i wouldn't be able to answer that
question 70
70 so if a stock price is going down
yeah that means that people are getting
fired okay and that's what people don't
understand people always push back and
say danielle the stock market's not the
economy i'm like i get it
but based on the ceo and his stock price
and if the stock price can't do mergers
and acquisitions and buy out other
companies and try and grow if the stock
price falls they're like we got to cut
costs here
so heads are going to roll and i don't
think that i don't think that the
democrats are thinking all the way
through this process because it's going
to trickle down and hurt the ones who
are the most vulnerable as usual as
usual as usual that's what ends up
happening now look i'm going to push
back for just a second and say that when
you when you read about companies like
amazon not paying taxes for years and
years and years you're like
every company should have to pay its own
you shouldn't have a tax code that's so
full of loopholes that you don't have to
pay a minimum level of taxes well you
know how you know you know you know how
you would fix that yeah rip up the tax
code and say pay 15 call it a day i'd
even rip up the tax code get rid of
lobbyists
that's simple yeah you get rid of
lobbyists so you get rid of lobbyists
half that stuff would be done because
why do so many of these big corporations
have a you know uh uh uh executive
office in d.c because because they're
writing
a writing show
that is a byproduct this is this is when
people ask why why are such uh
billionaires on the left or why are such
billionaires on the right or why is it
because
when you get to that level it's not
about taxes anymore it's about laws
right it's about and the way you get
that is by hiring the best lobbyists who
go lobby for you to pass a certain law
they're writing the laws let's get real
that's the point so if we got rid of
lobbyists and that model was gone
this this game politicians would be very
different we would be more american we
would be more american yeah we can all
dream right there's also no doubt who
those tax loopholes favor the mom and
pop shop or the big corporations oh
exactly it's always a small business
owner all when you when you hear
thresholds like 400 000
you're saying to yourself
what's a small business owner gonna do
if you because you're taxing an employee
out of of of work that's what you're
doing with a small business owner it
shouldn't be a sin to make 400 000 and
employ people it just shouldn't and if
the tax if it comes down to the taxes or
the people you're going to lose an
employee
again these policies are not properly
thought through
and by the way they're not even read
we talk every day that that you know
then the new bill is going to be 1.7
trillion and biden's going to make
law so we can read what probably just
make that thing so long that no one will
put the time in to actually read
everything that's at the bottom pelosi
pelosi famously said let's let's pass it
first and then read it god that's
unbelievable you know do you think some
of the uber wealthy are going damn it
mitt romney why are you giving these
guys more ideas now they're going to try
to tax that somehow i wonder if it's
going to be very hard for them yeah
somebody tweeted out something brilliant
they were like so if you're attacking
taxing untaxed gains right
unrealized gains what's going to happen
if the stock price falls is uncle sam
going to write this person a check back
and give him a refund
for what they taxed because unrealized
is unrealized but what what if the value
is lost what if what if the ceo gets run
over by a train
and he's worth you know he is the
company and all of a sudden the stock
price goes from 400 to 200
is the government going to write the
check back for having taxed un
unrealized gains i don't think it works
that way they're not thinking this stuff
through you know what the first thing i
thought of on this story from mitt
romney was is that why bill gates has
bought all this ranch land and all this
farmland he is the largest land owner in
the in the country yeah you should be
turning it into more farmland than
anyone in the entire country i mean 100
or maybe millions of acres like it's
understood well yeah
look at that but look you know but that
that gets you to a much bigger
discussion about corn and soybeans and
pork and china buying one of the biggest
pork producers in the united states i
mean food is national security
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]